hi I'm Ryan and I'm going to be watching
the trailers for the raid 2 because
apparently my reaction to the second and
third trailer of this movie is very
important to some people let me just
read you a couple of comments real fast
no I did a trailer reaction with a few
of with a couple of my buddies for the
quiet ones this horror movie that got
great reviews at Sundance and here's
what they said as a comment box
the prototype guy where is the raid 2
red band trailer reaction as you
promised apparently I made a covenant
with this guy if you've seen it already
let me know and bTW what did you think
of the first one that's the first one
and good nyaaa 1 2 3 4 5 Jenaya can i
don't know he's probably Muslim or
something please please do a reaction to
the new raid domestic trailer it came
out like four or five days ago please
please and if you haven't seen the first
raid movie watch it now okay so by
popular demand I have to watch two
trailers though I'm not going to make
separate videos no you're going to get a
special episode tonight where you get to
watch two trailers in two my reactions
back-to-back I feel like such an [ __ ]
okay so I'm gonna watch the domestic
trailer first because the second trailer
is the red band trailer and the domestic
trailer you know it's censored and [ __ ]
so and then we're going to go all crazy
and I know my hair looks a little crazy
today
that's because whatever I do these
videos in my home I don't really care
what I look like anymore except if there
are some good-looking ladies out there
who want to leave a comment below I will
start combing my hair and cutting it or
something if you think this face would
look better with better hair well let's
face it it's me I'm pretty [ __ ] sexy
alright here we go let's get our raid on
let's get raided
Sony Pictures Classics general verdict
over come over it tell her to be honey
the baby's gonna get some cool action
since Nikita mobilised what I in number
see that was Pam come break I'm an
American teen
this would not be as cool in English oh
[ __ ]
I look so badass and there hasn't even
been action yet oh nice
I wish they'd shown you that fight
that just looks like a barrage of crazy
awesome action I haven't even seen the
first one yet but you just wait I'm
going to watch that first one and I'll
do an entire video and me reacting it
I'm just [ __ ] mean I wanted to
actually do that that was domestic that
was American style and it already looked
violent and badass now we're gonna watch
the red band trailer where I'm sure some
of it is the same except it'll be a
little bit more blood but who knows I
could be wrong then again I am Ryan
right
god I love the cinematography
no he's not going to do it
oh I have the biggest chills right now
literally for some reason it's not my
whole body but like the right side of my
body has all these chills right now and
it feels excellent that was not the same
kind of traitor that I was wrong I could
see why they wanted me to watch two
different trailers and yeah deaf film I
said it the first time and I'm gonna say
it the second and third time it looks
[ __ ] badass
yeah the second trailer was better
seriously when I you know stopped
filming I'm gonna start punching a wall
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome cuz I'm
gonna be just like that character I
don't know that name - everybody was